ce sont les premières courses en
rentrant des vacances d'été l'achat des
fournitures scolaires cahiers stylos
quatre couleurs des surligneurs couleurs
pastel des produits qui sentent bon la
rentrée 2021 dans cette enseigne
spécialisée installé à coignières le
rush de l'achat des fournitures
scolaires a démarré dès le début du mois
d'août là ça fait déjà deux bonnes
semaines que le rush a bien commencé on
a eu énormément de monde et surtout
beaucoup de préparation de listes
scolaires cette année c'est plus le
qualitatif qui est mise en avant avec la
fabrication made in france ou alors
surtout des produits en fait écolo et on
a notamment cette année une collection
donc green bay julie ou en fait nous
avons les agendas ainsi que les notebook
qui sont conçus en fait en papier
recyclé en encre végétale et la
couverture et un zeste d'orange avec ces
nouvelles tendances la qualité des
fournitures et rechercher avec un
certain coup à la clé d'après les
premières tendances le panier moyen
aurait augmenté d'environ 1% par rapport
à 2020 d'après ce qu'on voit sur la
liste je pense que ça va être 50 60
euros en général on s'en sort pour 200
euros par enfant j'ai pas d'idée précise
je suis la lys de chaque enfant d'après
une étude de l'association familles de
france le panier moyen pour un élève
entrant en classe de 6ème s'élève à 200
euros